THE DOW ABOVE 20,000.
THANK YOU.
SEE YOU LATER.
>> Ed: CORONAVIRUS CASES SKY
ROCKETING IN NEW YORK CITY.
IT ACCOUNTS FOR UP 70% OF THE
STATES CASES.
MAYOR BILL DE BLASIO WARNING
HOSPITALS ONLY HAVE A FEW WEEKS
OF SUPPLIES LEFT AND GOVERNOR
CUOMO ORDERED BUSINESSES TO KEEP
75% OF THEIR WORKERS HOME.
>> CLEAR COMMUNICATION.
CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION.
BECAUSE MISINFORMATION, EMOTION
AND FEAR AND PANIC IS TRULY MORE
DANGEROUS THAN THE VIRUS AT THIS
POSITION IN MY OPINION.
>> Ed: DAVID LEE MILLER IS IN
NEW YORK WITH MORE DETAILS.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, IN THE BATTLE.
CORONAVIRUS, NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
BILL DE BLASIO SAID THE CITY IS
ON THE FRONT LINE AND IS RUNNING
OUT OF SUPPLIES.
AT LEAST 26 PEOPLE IN THE CITY
HAVE DIED FROM THE VIRUS.
AND 4,000 HAVE NOW TESTED
POSITIVE.
THE MAYOR ADDRESSED REPORTERS ON
A REMOTE LOCATION TO PREVENT
SPREAD OF THE DISEASE.
HE IS ASKING WASHINGTON FOR
MASKS AND VENTILATORS AND OTHER
ITEMS.
HE WARNED WITHOUT THE HELP OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TIME IS
RUNNING OUT.
>> I KNOW OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS THE CAPACITY WITH THE FINIST
MILITARY IN THE WORLD.
THE LARGEST BY FAR.
EXTRAORDINARY RESOURCES.
THEY CAN CREATE ANY CREDIT LINE
THEY WANT TO SAVE THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS.
BUT WE ARE NOT SEEING THAT.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> START TODAY STATEWIDE IN NEW
YORK EVERYONE ELSE CAN ONLY HAVE
25% OF THE EMPLOYEES SHOW UP FOR
WORK.
GOVERNOR CUOMO TO PROVIDE
STRUGGLING NEW YORKERS WITH
FINANCIAL RELIEF ORDERED BANKS
TO SUSPEND MORTGAGE PAYMENTS AND
FEES FOR UP TO 90 DAYS.
WE ARE JUST LEARNING THAT NEW
YORK STATE, NEW JERSEY,
CONNECTICUT AND PENNSYLVANIA
CALLED FOR SLOWING OF ALL
BARBERSHOPS AND SALONS BY 8 P.M.
TOMORROW.
IN CONNECTICUT THEY POSTPONED
THE JUNE PRIMARY.
IN NEW JERSEY IT TOOK A HARD
TOLL ON ONE FAMILY.
3 SIBLINGS AND THEIR MOTHER ALL
DIED FROM THE VIRUS.
3 OTHERS IN THE FAMILY ARE
HOSPITALIZED.
19 OTHERS ARE QUARANTINED.
IT’S NOT CLEAR WHY THIS ONE
FAMILY WAS SO HARD HIT BY THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ACCORDING TO PUBLISHED REPORTS,
FAMILY MEMBERS HAD RECENTLY ALL
TAKEN PART IN A ROUTINE DINNER.
AT THAT DINNER THERE WAS ONE
PERSON WHO HAD BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL WHO LATER
DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOW IT APPEARS EVEN THE ROUTINE
CAN BE DEADLY.
>> Ed: A HEART BREAKING CASE.
THAT GIVES YOU AN IDEA WHY WE